[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in albert breer senior nfl
reporter lead content strategist what do
you think of that take the happiest guy
that brady came back is ben
roethlisberger so he doesn't have to
share the stage in canton ohio that
makes sense too because isn't it
alphabetical the um
the
speeches right so
like not only would he have to share it
but it also could be like there could be
like you know 75 percent of the crowd
there to see tom brady they all clear
out after he after he's done you know
what do you make of bruce smith coming
out after tony becely i thought bruce
smith is the one who called biselli or
told biselli that he was going into the
hall of fame why is why did bruce smith
turn on tony bacelli's induction into
the hall of fame
i don't know that i heard about this
oh
yeah
wow i missed this huh yeah
i think bruce uh was asked about biselli
going in and the fact that beselli
part of the reason why he's going in is
because of his play against bruce smith
yes so bruce we've been like the playoff
game in like 95 yeah i think so but then
yeah bruce says well he didn't even uh
he wasn't even the blind side tackle for
his you know brunel's left-handed and
you know tony played left tackle and
bruce is saying you know this is a bad
precedent paulie you got the uh the
quote yeah bruce smith said on a serious
level i i and other hall of famers
believe it's a horrible precedent to
negatively zero in on a standing member
of the hall of fame's play in order to
validate the candidacy of a nominee
that's deep
yeah but it's a horrible precedent
part of making the hall of fame is big
moments right like and if that's a big
moment for tony beselli
and i don't think that i don't the
argument with tony beselli was ever he
wasn't good enough it was did he do it
for long enough it was like terrell
davis right yeah
yeah
i mean like and once you open the door
with terrell davis i think
more start we're gonna we're gonna face
this a bunch too because if you think
about it like
i mean that was calvin johnson he's now
in
um it's gonna be patrick willis right
like i think patrick willis is probably
in that category where he was awesome
but
it's like for a little bit of a shorter
period of time
so like with biselli i think the
question was never how great he was and
i don't think he's getting in off of one
game because i don't think that was the
argument like the argument and i look
like i'm i was in high school when
bicelli was in his prime um but
like
i remember bracelet being one of the
best tackles in football the question
really wasn't like how great he was when
he was at his best
that was good enough to get the hall of
fame was did he do it long enough so
that has nothing to do with one great
game anyway but i like how bruce smith
says it's a bad precedent to allow this
to happen i would think criticizing
somebody who's going into the hall of
fame is a bad precedent to happen too
for somebody who's already in the hall
of fame also i campaigned for biselli
for years i want to campaign for zach
thomas because i think zach thomas was
one of the brightest football players i
ever saw
miami dolphins linebacker and he has a
resume there and i think he's been a
finalist a few times
if you talk to
and i asked peyton manning about this
and he said it would drive me crazy
you know you make a call and then he
makes a defensive call he he already
knows what's going to happen right and
and you take it from these it's like
when tom brady said jason taylor is a
hall of famer
okay
i believe you you know when when players
tell you about players i you know then i
i'm interested they know more than
anybody yeah because they're the ones
that like they're the ones that are
sitting there on wednesday and thursday
in a dark room looking at them you know
what i mean like it's not just playing
against them it's like we have to study
them and then we have to game plan
against them and we know
like a quarterback knows like who his
team is most worried about right like
for tom brady for all those years in
that division
i mean it was jason taylor that was the
biggest problem for them you know and so
and zac zach thomas is right there with
him like i
it's it's an interesting like underrated
part of jimmy johnson's career because
obviously like you know what he did at
the university of miami what he did with
the cowboys that's always going to be
kind of at the top of his resume but if
you look at that defense that he built
in miami
with
taylor
zach thomas sam madison patrick certain
like it was a
like if they had just gotten the
quarterback position right man like
they may have done
what he did in dallas in miami because
like they like it wasn't a disaster they
got a lot of things right there we're
talking albert breer uh monday morning
quarterback
you know speaking of dallas jimmy
johnson like what is the hold up here
with jerry jones putting jimmy johnson
in the ring of honor
i think
well is he going in this year
jerry doesn't commit
so like i think he said he wanted him go
to go into the pro football hall of fame
before the ring i look there was
something like that i mean there was
look for a long time it was what
everybody thinks it was which was
about credit for
what happened from 1989 to 19 or 1989 to
1994 in that organization
and i do think that like the acrimony
from that period and
the like territory marking i think was
an important piece to jerry and
so like at this point i
i i can't imagine there's any reason to
keep him out like
he he won two super bowls you could
argue he's really responsible for
winning three right yeah
which is more than landry won
so i i don't know what would keep him
out damn well he said in january that he
had not heard anything as uh as late as
two weeks ago hadn't heard anything
about the ring of honor and it's like
because he went into canton last year
right jimmy did yeah
so like i think that that was always the
like i
maybe that's why he was asked because i
thought the plan was always when he got
into because they were sitting up there
on the stage yeah last summer right yeah
and jerry and jimmy had that moment on
the set i think was the nbc set right
like where
jerry told jimmy you're going in
and that was the whole idea at least
remember i remember that's what i
remember hearing about it was the
cowboys were gonna be like okay like
he's going into the hall of fame
and then you know teams a lot of times
they'll bring the you know inductee back
and give them the day
and they did that
and so like it was like we're gonna give
him that day and then next year we'll
induct him into the ring of honor i
don't know what would keep him out at
this point i thought
to a large degree the hatchet had been
buried there and it was time to put him
up there there's no excuse for him not
to be in the ring yeah but that's where
you get a couple of drinks in you and
i'm going to put you in the ring ring of
fame there yeah jerry walking up to the
stage just winking at somebody and said
watch this
all right help me understand
the process now with deshaun watson that
if you know washington post said on
friday the headline nfl will argue for
significant suspension of desean watson
what would be your definition of
significant suspension
i think the full year um and i think
that this was there was some momentum
towards this being
like a maybe eight to ten game
suspension
i do think to some degree what's
happened over the last couple of weeks
could change things um especially if
watson wasn't
fully open and honest
with the league and with the browns
about all this stuff and i'm not talking
about the stuff that was already there
i'm talking about the stuff that's more
recent the 23rd lawsuit the 24th lawsuit
i think everybody knew the 23rd lawsuit
was coming i'm less sure about the 24th
lawsuit and then obviously that number
that was in the time story that he
solicited 66 women over 18 months was he
honest with the league about that
if he wasn't i think the punishment
becomes harsher and i think a heavy
punishment here would be a year
um and you know could you see more than
that albert more than so
like you know a lot of people have
brought up the trevor bowers suspension
right
i think the way the league could couch
this if they won a year
is they they could say okay he already
sat out 2021 no that wasn't a suspension
but he missed a year of his career got
paid
it got paid but he missed a year of his
career
and now he's going to miss a second
season so he's going to have missed two
full years of his career when you're
talking about time lost
that's equal to trevor bowers
time lost now the money's a different
thing obviously because of the way the
contract structure i mean desean
potentially could only lose a million
dollars
you know if in in in that two-year
period but
um you know i could see where they would
say and couch it as a one-year
suspension is really he's been off the
field now for two years
but i do think like that this
what's happened the last few weeks has
changed some things as we've talked
about before i do think that the june
30th deadline which we're coming up on
that now is significant um that's the
deadline for pre-trial discovery
and i think what the last few weeks have
has illustrated to everybody is that
you really aren't going to be out of
this until next year at the earliest and
new information could keep coming
between now and then and so whatever you
do whatever punishment you levy
if you're the league you have to leave
open the possibility
that you have to alter that punishment
because new information becomes
available
so i think that they feel like when they
get to july
the arbitrator sue robinson the league
the union feel that they'll have enough
information to make a conscious decision
while leaving that opening that they
could alter the punishment going forward
i even had somebody say to me over the
weekend like is it possible there are
two suspensions here is it possible
there's a suspension now for what they
know
and then you know you get to 2023
and once the trials start once once the
court proceedings start
you reassess before 2023 on whether
you're going to let him play the full
2023 season
there's just a lot of moving parts here
based on the way that information has
kind of become public over the course of
the last two years and or the last year
and a half
and i really think it's relevant how
much of that information was disclosed
by deshaun to both the league and the
browns
help me understand the process because
the commissioner doesn't dole out the
discipline right but he will hear the
appeal
and then he could hand out punishment on
an appeal
so
yeah so it basically
then this was negotiated in the 2020 cba
um
the the the initial decision it goes to
sue robinson who is a um an independent
arbitrator um who's you know the ux u.s
district court judge
she will make the she will hear the
cases from the nfl and the case from the
nfl pa
and she's gathered all the information
she will make a decision
after that the commissioner has the
power
to alter the punishment
and
the only instance in which he can't
alter the punishment is if there's no
punishment so
if it's just a fine or there's no
suspension he can't add a suspension to
that
but if there's a suspension he can alter
the suspension
after that the nfl pa has the right to
appeal
the decision made by robinson and by the
commissioner
and so
this is sort of
it's going to be interesting to see what
happens because
you know obviously the arbitrator does
swing a big stick here and i and i don't
think that the commissioner in such a
high-profile case is gonna wanna
overrule
the uh the arbitrator that said
the nfl and the nfl pa um and the the
arbitrator are all they're all very
aware of the optics which i think is why
you saw things become so public over the
last couple of weeks like the nfl
getting it out there right like that we
want a year and the nfl pa getting it
out there that their case is that daniel
snyder and robert kraft and jerry
richardson weren't subject to this type
of punishment in their cases and so
i think you're seeing a pr battle kind
of happen ahead of sue robinson's
decision
yeah i get that feeling too that there's
a taffy poll going on yeah publicly and
then all of a sudden you know because
sometimes you send the story out just to
get reaction like a significant
suspension
and then i talked to a source i said
what is a significant suspension and he
said my definition is different than you
know what roger goodell's or this judge
will be and i think that's the
interesting part of that also yeah baker
mayfield you know sort of
hovering but can't land anywhere at what
point does carolina say either
this is a bargain
or it's not a bargain and we're going to
stay with sam darnold
um well i will say they
they were happy with sam in the spring
doesn't mean they they
necessarily locked in with him as their
starter but
he i think showed a little bit more edge
and a little bit more fight over the
last nine weeks than they had seen in
his first year there and ben mcadoo
thinks there's something to work with i
think the way you want to look at the
panthers view of this
is bringing in baker mayfield would be
an effort to raise the floor at the
position for them that they feel like
maybe baker mayfield's not the long-term
answer but he at the very least could
give them average quarterback play which
they are not sure
they can get from sam darnold based on
the way he played last year and matt
corral based on the offense he's coming
out of in the transition that's not a
good rallying cry there albert i know it
sounds bad but that but but that you
know what though that illustrates why
they aren't willing to take on the money
right here's this is gonna
honestly i think cleveland is going to
have to take on like
70 of the salary for the panthers to do
this like this is going to have to be a
good deal for the panthers because what
they look at what they're looking at now
is
baker mayfield would come in and could
provide us with average play at the
position like 16th 17th 18th best
quarterback in the league play
which they haven't been able to get the
last couple of years right so
they feel like if they can do that then
like all right like now we can open a
quarterback competition and we'll see if
somebody can rise above that level
but if that's really what you're looking
for it's just average quarterback play
well you're not going to
fork over a draft pick and another 18
million dollars to get it well i can
just see opening day here's the chant
you're going to hear from the crowd
well guys but like here's the thing like
look at like who's the 16th best
quarterback in the nfl right now i mean
probably a decent player right ryan
tannehill
okay so
if ryan tannehill's the quarterback of
the panthers this year they're okay
right
like their defense is getting better
they you know drafting offensive linemen
sixth overall they're skill players like
christian mccaffrey and dj moore
they're not like it's not a bad roster
the quarterbacks just held them back
and i think getting out they believe
that at least they believe that getting
average quarterback play
in 2022 will make them a whole lot more
competitive than they've been the last
couple of years especially if some of
the young guys on defense like brian
burns um or jc horn can develop the way
they think those guys are capable of
thank you amber
thank you dan thank you above average
albert breer by the way above average
yeah somebody there's got to be a bigger
winner than ben roethlisberger and
brady's comeback would it be scottie
miller maybe
the wide receiver
yeah why would he be a bigger winner
well because you think of it like chris
godwin's already gotten paid like i know
from having covered tom brady for 18
years that guy has made a ton of people
millionaires right like like you look at
the receivers that have come through
there the offense like all the players
that have come through the coaches that
have come through there yeah it's got to
be somebody like that byron leftwich
okay
buyer and leftwich okay all right that's
the biggest amount all right all right
because if he doesn't have brady this
year
and they're terrible on offense all of a
sudden what happens to his head coaching
candidacy i like that
thank you albert yes
all right thanks dan albert breer monday
morning quarterback the senior nfl
reporter